The Syndicate is real do they know who
you are a rogue nation trained to do
what we do they're coming after us with
everything they've got
so what's the play you want to bring
down the syndicate it's impossible i
unban on for famishing weekend we've
never met before but you've done a few
premieres here tom
what do you like about this venue I love
it here because it's the sound the big
screen it's just very exciting how
important it is to see Mission
Impossible on the big screen you ask me
that now it's such a kind of immersive
experience you just sort of like it's
just there it is huge and you get taken
alarms incredible Rebecca look there any
part of the challenging production that
felt like Mission Impossible Michelle
one of the biggest challenges for me was
overcoming vertigo and jumping off the
piano rooftop hi Tom it looks like
you're up to your crazy stunt again
which slow will look best on IMAX but
your Jeanie you're gonna have to decide
every one of them were designed for the
big screen whether it's a motorcycle the
underwater sequence put you right in the
middle of the action this big screen why
should the fancy yeah now I want you to
choose your next words very carefully go
to see it on IMAX because you're never
gonna see it bigger and better
they're great cinemas and a big screen
it's a big experience hi I'm Sophie from
sorry and I was just wondering what's
your favorite Mission Impossible gadget
hello Sophie from Surrey my favorite
Mission Impossible gadget would probably
be the the masked machine I could be Tom
Tom could be me that's the magic of
Mission Impossible desperate times
desperate measures